welcome to the shop show hot take
powered by rain body fuel
listen if you've ever wanted to try
kratom now is the time my friends over
at happy hipple herbals are giving away
kratom 100
free that's right free kratom son no
cost you at all seriously this is the
perfect time to go see what kratom is
all about you look at your boy here
right now i'm on kratom on stage doing
stand up i'm on kratom the 7 thousand
podcasts i do every week i'm on kratom i
swear by kratom but you gotta get it
from a trusted source and that's why
happy hippo is my go-to
again you can try it for free 100
risk free 100 free to you see why kratom
is known as the limitless pill from your
boy here or you can visit happy hippo
herbals.com use promo code thickboy for
20 off for life you can use that code as
many times as you want that's happy
hippo
herbals.com use promo code thick boy for
twins off for life what's up thickies
our boy nate diaz is trending in the
fight world for a variety of reasons one
big tweet got it done now before i give
you this hot take on nate diaz there's a
misconception that me and nate diaz have
some weird beef insert video
here
that was just a misunderstanding i was
doing a job for show time i had to
basically pitch on why conor mcgregor
can win the fight i think he took it as
me siding with conor mcgregor and then
the trolls got to hold the video and put
some words that never happened but i
actually like nate and nick for that
matter i like both of them i think they
represent the sport
great and i think they're complete
badasses and they're actually great for
the brand and that's why they're two of
the biggest stars even though they don't
win that often it doesn't matter they've
cemented their legacy and they're still
fantastic and they're fan favorites for
that reason so let's get into it nate
has been crying for the ufc to release
him he has one fight left on his
contract if you look at his tweets well
it's pretty clear what he wants to do uh
a short time ago he put i'm trying to
get on this bellator mma card in april
with my boy yancey menderos in hawaii
what's up with it bellator so that's him
saying hey i want to play for the other
team
and right after that he tweeted out
taking a piss on the ufc pi i could do
this because i get paid more than all
you guys and they won't cut me fair
point pissing on the apec center
and then he also may 28 tweeted out i've
been trying to fight for a year and
months i also tried to fight hamzat for
the last month and a half but he was
hurt had visa issues overweight and now
his [ __ ] ass is off getting married
instead of fighting what the [ __ ]
i'm trying to get a fight with a real
fighter asap july lfg for you boomers
out there that stands for let's [ __ ]
go
and then most recently and that's why
we're here he tweeted out ufc release
he put should put me but he didn't he
said release now please or give me fight
with anyone in july or august i have
bigger [ __ ] to do
also including this is a video of jake
paul knocking woodley out cold so this
is
nate diaz alluding to he wants to be
released if you don't give him a fight
because he has bigger [ __ ] to do like
fight jake paul which he thinks he'd
make all the money in the world now
would he make all the money in the world
well that's up for debate so the main
reason why nate is so upset and
um impatient with the ufc and keep
saying give me a fight give me a fight
figure it out everybody all these mma
experts and analysts out there and i
don't consider myself an expert or an
analyst for that matter but figure it
out all they're trying to do is nate has
one fight left on his contract all
they're doing is melting this thing out
because it's a marathon not a sprint for
the ufc they're just waiting for conor
get that old leg back and he looks
better than ever and he's jacked right
now on a yacht where god knows where
usada sure as hell doesn't so all
they're trying to do is get
connor healthy because there is no way
in hell they're letting nate diaz go
without that trilogy fight with conor
mcgregor because that is their biggest
fight that's not a title fight it's a
it's a big fight
is it their biggest fight no but it's
still a big ass fight and they're gonna
make a ton of money on it but when it
comes down to
nate leaving the ufc
will he actually make more money well
let's look how much nate has made in his
most recent fights in the ufc in his
most recent fights when he fought conor
the first time he made 620 thousand
dollars that we know of now remember
there is kind of an under table
agreement here where if dana's feeling
friendly he will pay these guys into the
table more money than it's reported so
we don't actually know but we're going
based off the analytics that we can get
online so nate diaz made 620 000 for the
first conor fight in the second counter
fight he made
2.2 million dollars that's a lot of
chatter baby and then against leon
edwards most recent fight he made 1.1
million this is a lot of money now is it
more money than he would uh make
fighting jake paul
i don't think so for a variety of
reasons i think one of the reasons nate
wants to leave is he knows he can make
more money he's also not getting any
younger so
for him
i think the best case scenario would
you're not getting out of the contract
one of the reasons why the ufc is the
ufc and these other leagues can't really
compete because the ufcs have the best
lawyers their lawyers are second to none
those contracts are air tight those
contracts are tied as a seals [ __ ]
there's nothing getting in there's
nothing getting out there's nothing you
can do about it and also the way it
works for you guys
you should know this a lot of people say
well just let nate go or how come nate
can't just get out of the contract if
you're not going to fight him well the
way the business works is if you have a
fight left on your contract they usually
try to negotiate before you have one
fight left nate decided not to do that
so he has one fight left now he has to
contractually
finish the one fight before he can move
on but there's a caveat to that if the
ufc offers him fights and he turns them
down i'm not saying he's done this i do
not know this but if he turns down a
fight that prolongs his contract six
months regardless whether he has three
fights five fights one fight if you turn
down a fight it prolongs the contract
does that make sense so let's say he had
uh uh one fight left and you have six
months to get it done the ufc asks you
to fight and nate goes i don't like the
hamzap fight no i'm not saying he did
this this is all hypothetical but if he
goes i have six months left i have to do
one fight you offer me hamza i don't
like that matchup i'm not taking it that
doesn't mean he can get out of his
contract that means it prolongs his
contract another six months
now if he has six months left or a year
left and ufc doesn't offer many fights
then his contract would expire and
that's on the ufc
but i would assume the ufc is not doing
that they're very smart that the top of
the frickin
ponzi scheme of fighting for a reason i
mean say ponzi scheme you know what i'm
saying lack of vocabulary to be honest
but there's a reason why they're at
where they're at you know what i'm
saying their contracts are airtight so
to me from the outside looking in it
looks like nate
they might have offered him fights it's
not the best fights but it just keeps
prolonging his contract and but all the
ufc is doing they know he's going to
turn on the fights or maybe he's accept
the fights and fell through or like he
said hamzlot's getting married or you
know out of shape doesn't want to take
the fight for what a variety of reasons
but the ufc is offering fights just to
keep giving these little nibbles these
nibbles they're just dragging it out
until conor goes i'm ready to go and
then ufc says come on down that's all
they're doing they're just buying time
until they can line up the connor nate
diaz fight the trilogy fight so going
back is that going to make the most
money possible for nate diaz personally
i don't think so here's the reason
both gentlemen connor and nate diaz
they've won one fight since 2016 in the
last seven years they've won one fight
now they're both
bigger than life personalities they're
both legends they're both first ballot
hall of famers sure
but
i think the excitement of that fight for
both gentlemen coming off you know good
amount of losses one out of seven it's a
tough sell but not with these two i
still think the fight sells but will it
sell like it did in that second fight
where nate made two million dollars i
think connor's gonna make his money
regardless he has a different deal he's
the green elephant well the rest of them
even if they're stars or gray elephants
conor's gonna get his this isn't about
conor this about nate what's best for
nate well what would be best for nate is
if he plays ball because you're not
gonna have the contract you're gonna
have to take a fight against conor
mcgregor that trilogy fight before they
let you go anywhere else so you're gonna
have to play ball play ball you're gonna
make a good amount of money fighting
conor mcgregor now win or lose
jake's still going to fight you man that
fight's not going anywhere jake's only
getting better uh you know he's he's
fighting tommy fury next and who knows
what's after that about mike tyson all
right great grand wonderful
but i think for jake
for him to fight a guy like nate diaz
it gives him so much credibility for
jake still his number one priority
whether he admits it or not and i do
know jake
whether he's going to admit or not he
wants the validation from his peers he
wants the validation from the fight fans
go all right this guy's a legit fighter
he i know he's making money like he's
canelo alvarez i don't think he's there
yet but he's making a truckload of money
but so that's why he gets all this hate
but i think for jake for him in the back
of his mind he wants to be validated so
i asked you guys if he fought nate diaz
does that validate jake for you if he
fought him and knocked out nate diaz
does that do it for you because it does
it for me
because people can say oh well he's just
an mma guy sure he's a fantastic mma guy
but not only is the mma guy but his
specialty is boxing sure as hell not
kicking sure so not checking kicks nate
specializes in boxing and jiu jitsu
outside that
it's not what he does so nate has been
in the camp with andre ward his
brother's been in camp with andre ward
they fancied himself boxers so nate's
not going to be like a woodley or ben
asking who looks uncomfortable in boxing
gloves doesn't really know the boxing
ring it's kind of a new experience for
him for nate it's gonna be a pretty
familiar territory and i think jake's in
for a pretty rude awakening with nate
diaz and the pressure he brings and also
the volume of punches that he brings
these other guys sit back and let jake
do his thing nate isn't gonna do that
so overall
well nate make more money if let's say
in this strange world if the ufc is
really some right now let's say off all
these tweets dana sees it
uncle dana goes all right get him out of
him sick of this stuff he pissed on our
building that we built he's talking
about [ __ ] online which i don't think
dana cares would say does he piss on the
building all right let's cut him
so would nate make more money and the
answer is yes he would definitely make
more money that's why he wants to go
over there and do it again he's not
getting any younger the jake paul fights
there you have the logan paul fight
eventually you have the weird mike tyson
stuff could potentially happen you have
all these
circus acts i would almost say all these
uh celebrity fights even though i i do
consider jake a real fighter so you know
but you have these you know not your
conventional fights that he could take
on and earn more money because the ufc's
business model since 2019 since they
signed with espn it's no longer star
driven sure the stars bring eyeballs but
the ufc really doesn't care they want to
give you good fights and they're doing
that and thank god they do that and i
love it but they don't really care all
they have to do is fulfill their
contract and give espn whatever it is 46
fights a year and they're getting their
money regardless so if you're a big ufc
star
i mean sure the ufc likes stars but
that's not their business model anymore
it's not deal on 18. so for guys like
nate diaz mazvidal
connors of the outlier uh jon jones
francis um you know poirier volkanovsky
izzy
the ufc really doesn't care about your
pay-per-view numbers they just need to
put on fights so it almost hurts your
negotiation abilities when you're
sitting at the table it hurts these guys
so i do think nate would make more money
if he was cut today and when fought the
jake paul's the logan paul's of the
world and whatever else is out there for
him and then also not to mention the
sponsorship his sponsorship would be way
higher so can he beat the 2 million he
got in the second counter fight
absolutely can he beat the 1.1 million
to fight leon edwards absolutely no
question about it because you look at
jake paul's last opponents if you look
at uh woodley you know he said he made
flat 2 million not to mention the
pay-per-view percentage he says the most
money he's ever made he said he made
more money in that one fight than he did
fighting in a few years in the ufc
he was a champ you all must have forgot
welterweight champ woodley made more
money in one fight against jake paul
than he did in
a few years of being a champion ufc
you don't think nate diaz can make more
money come on you don't think that's a
bigger fight you know you don't think
that's selling more pay-per-views you
don't think he's getting big-time
sponsorships bigger sponsorships than
venom
okay
okay
of course you'd make more money you like
ben askin even look at ben asking it was
reporting made 500 000 flat i know ben
ben told me he made seven figures the
most money he's ever made in the history
of his
illustrious fight career that's ben
askren
he made seven figures
nate made seven figures fight leon
edwards
you're telling me that nate diaz can't
leave the ufc and go make more money
you're out of your mind of course you'd
make more money more money not only
fighting these guys which are i think
easier fights for them but also more
money in sponsorship
but here's the caveat to all this i
think the move for nate is
and you're gonna have to that was all
hypothetical because for nate you have
to get that last fight for the ufc
they're going to get theirs you got to
pay the piper the piper's uncle dana
white you have one fighting a contract
they're not going to let you carry on
and mosey your way over to jake paul and
make more money than god you're going to
have to fight
conor mcgregor for the trilogy fight and
wrap that whole legacy fight up that's
what you're gonna have to do
you're gonna make a lot of money doing
that and it's a fight you can win so
there's really no downsides if i'm nate
diaz i get the tweets that's what he
does and fans love it and he flips the
bird to the boss and [ __ ] the man i get
all that i love it [ __ ] it's my first
hot take on it because i love it so much
but at the same time it's all good in
the nds world you're gonna eventually
get that fight maybe december maybe
january depend what conor's doing on
those yachts who knows but you're going
to get that fight and we're going to be
excited to watch it you make tons of
money doing that and that's when loser
draw the jake fights not go anywhere so
let's the let's double dip here let's
dip from the ufc then dip on out and
fight jake paul because it doesn't
matter win lose or draw the jake paul
fights waiting for you at the end of
this
very very rich rainbow that you are
headed down so you're gonna make more
money than god and it's all good
patience grasshopper it's happening
you're gonna fight conor wrap the
trilogy up and then you'll fight jake
paul that's how it goes for you so these
next 12 months for nate diaz
you're going sizzler you're making all
the money in the world and we're proud
of you here at thick boy
but i would say this
here's the question of the fans out
there leaving the comments
if nate diaz were to lose to jake paul
what's that do for his legacy how do you
guys feel about it
that's why i think there's more pressure
on nate than jake paul that's why i
think there's a lot of pressure on nate
if he were to leave the ufc and fight
the likes of a jake paul what does it do
for his legacy
what's it do if he were to lose to a
youtuber jake paul again buddy still he
was on the disney channel
a few years ago he's making youtube
videos with like pink lamborghinis and
[ __ ]
he just started fighting if he were to
knock nate diaz cold flat what's that do
for his legacy a lot of pressure a lot
of money either way it's a win-win for
nate diaz
i'll see you guys next time
you